six weeks from the start of the nfl
draft just four days away from the
beginning of free agency which uh
frankly i think should be delayed
in light of the broader events happening
in our country the situation reached
critical mass yesterday chris wednesday
march 11 2020 i think one of those days
that we will always remember because
that is the day that collectively our
government
our leaders
our sports leagues
and hopefully our people
decided to take very seriously
what this coronavirus reality means that
it's not just i'll be fine it's
we need to limit the spread to protect
those in our population who are most at
risk of dying from the illness and also
we need to do what we can to prevent our
health care facilities from being
hopelessly overrun by people who aren't
going to die but who need urgent
treatment
yeah well it's uh it's the right thing
to do by you know the ncaa they did a
good job hey no you know no fans of the
game that's going to be weird to watch
but nonetheless at least if they even go
for it they may not even
right right i know so we'll see where
that goes yes certainly um you know the
nba i think that was the correct measure
there especially with you know
uh the player on the utah jazz and go
bear and him him being you know testing
positive you know the big thing too to
me now just looking forward is what
happens with yeah you're right i mean
free agency
you know it can go on
it's going to make it difficult the
draft
that's going to be really tough i mean
you know if you can't meet players see
them in person get them on the board a
little bit go through personal workouts
that's going to be a game changer so
they might have to delay that and then
added to that i'm really interested and
intrigued to see what the nhl and major
league baseball do you know what what
are they going to do here going forward
they've yet to make any definitive
statement about how they're going to go
and they got games to be played and of
course the nhl is getting close to
playoff season here uh so
i'm just interested to see where all
this goes and we're all we're all in a
tough spot right now
there was a sense last night chris in
the aftermath of the nba suspending its
season just moments after the news came
out the jazz center rudy gobert tested
positive for coronavirus there was a
sense the nhl was going to follow suit
the nhl has not yet made any
announcements the statement last night
from the national hockey league uh we
are aware of the nba's decision to
indefinitely suspend its season due to a
player testing positive for coronavirus
the nhl is continuing to consult with
medical experts and is evaluating the
options we expect to have a further
update on thursday look this is a
serious decision to make in the absence
of any of your players testing positive
i think for the nba it was very simple
they had a conference call on wednesday
they were leaning toward playing games
in empty arenas but the speed with which
the suspension of the season happened
tells me that they understood one got
test positive right we're done and uh
hockey
i you know if a guy tests positive
uh
i i could see that same attitude that
we're done we can't have this spread
throughout every organization and then
beyond they can't be contributing to the
spread of this virus that could overrun
health care facilities and ultimately
endanger the lives of more americans
right whatever the mortality rate is and
anthony fauci the expert who has served
six different presidents he testified to
congress yesterday that the
the mortality rate we've heard it as
high as two or three it's one percent
that's still ten times higher than the
seasonal flu's mortality rate so this is
something we need to keep from
the most vulnerable members of our
society the elderly the people with uh
serious pre-existing conditions diabetes
respiratory issues etc and uh i i i feel
strongly about that and the light bulb
finally went on for me yesterday and i
just hope that what i experienced is
what more and more people will
experience the idea that it's not about
whether or not i survive it it's about
whether or not we can limit the spread
right to protect the people who need to
be protected and to not have our health
care systems overrun by all the people
who will need care in the event that
this thing does spread as as widely as
some fear it could yeah well i mean we
have models already that's where you
know you look at italy you look at
germany look at france there's been no
travel bans there's issues there
you know their their
their medical systems are being
exhausted right now because of that and
we don't we don't know where it's going
to end yet but where we're seeing is how
fast it can spread you know again a
place like italy i just go back to that
one more time yesterday alone had what
over 2 300 you know positive tests just
yesterday
so that just tells you how explosive
this thing can be and that's where it's
scary out of the fact mike you know just
with the mb mv nba thing and you know
the rudy gobert and that whole
conversation think about this too
you know and this is another thing where
i give the nba a lot of credit you know
they have basic they have told
that the teams that have played the utah
jazz in the last 10 to 12 days to go
into solitary confinement self
quarantine go right there i mean think
about that if you were a guy that had a
guard rudy gobert the last few days in
an nba basketball game what you're doing
at home right now going holy crap i was
all up in that guy's you know face i
could he was breathing on me i had his
sweat on my arm and my hand and you know
i hope you know so that that that's
where the nba was really smart to just
cut this right now and you know stop
further spread
rudy gobert thought he was being funny
the other day yeah he had a press
conference and he touched all of the
microphones and the recording devices
and said he wasn't scared of corona or
anything right yeah yeah and and those
reporters uh now there it is god they
they all need to be concerned that they
may have it as well it's not you know
it's it's
it's just it's it's sad that
something i almost tweeted last night
that i told you about i'm gonna change
the language but at times like this
you find out very quickly which people
among us truly care about their fellow
man and which people are selfish
jerk buttholes i like your text message
one better that you texted me that you
know
we just can't say it it's a different
word than jerk and it's a different word
than buttholes right now i'm telling you
it's true things like this are a great
character litmus test do you care about
your fellow man or are you selfish and
pigheaded and only concerned about the
things you want to watch the things you
want to do the places you want to go and
for a lot of people and we're going to
find out who those folks are in our
society but for a lot of people their
priorities are completely screwed up and
hopefully hopefully those folks will be
smoked out by this and hopefully in
their hearts they will understand
through the passage of time that it's
time for them to change yeah well this
is because this can mean life and death
for people as we've seen so this is
serious and if you're not taking it
serious then you know you're ignorant
you're a jerk you're you know a butthole
like florio said whatever it may be yeah
this is this is a time to yes we know
think about yourself but think about
everybody this is a worldwide problem
this is a humanity problem this is not
countries or anything like that we have
to protect each other wash your hands be
careful where you put them don't touch
your face don't be touching things that
you look at where you go oh there could
have been a thousand other hands on
there on a day uh you know today as is
you know i'm a germaphobe already so i
this is like crazy time for me i'm
literally looking at doorknobs being
like oh my gosh how many people have
touched that what how many noses have
been rubbed before they touch that i
mean that's where my mind goes on a
normal basis let alone where we're at
right now i mean i'm at the point where
you know i'm going to be taking my
sleeve down over my hand to grab the the
knob that way i mean but yet this is the
things we got to do right now just to
protect all of us
hey i mean i've been thinking about
because look for me and i understand for
people out there
it's a hardship to be at home
jobs that require you to show up and
work at a store and we can't have our
society collapse over this i mean there
are ways to to practice social
distancing and i think we all should be
sensitive to the urgency of staying at
least six feet away from each other but
you're right these surfaces who knows
how long it lives on the surfaces there
who reports out that maybe it lives a
lot longer than they realize it survives
in the air more than they realize right
but uh but uh you know for me i i mean i
i work at home and i rarely leave the
house as it is especially this time of
year with free agency coming but i think
about everything i mean i go down to the
store and you're right i mean how can i
open this door without actually having
to touch it i'm supposed to get a
haircut in a week and a half and no i
don't wear a toupee i'm supposed to get
my hair cut yeah uh i don't want to yeah
i'm thinking about just letting it ride
right but then if enough people do that
then the folks who are there to provide
that service they have no income and
that's just how the threads of our
society begin to come apart and you know
we're going to see that we're going to
see you know movie theater who's going
to the movies i don't go anyway
but hell there's no reason to go now no
and you know the the airline industry
there's so many industries that are
premised on people actually leaving
their house and doing things that are
going to be in in a bad way and and you
know whether it's raising money among
those of us who can continue about our
lives and can help those who will have
their lives affected in a negative way i
think we should be ready to do that at a
local level and at a broader level
hopefully some charities will pop up
where we can contribute and we will
encourage people to contribute to funds
that are there to help people who lose
money because their jobs have ended or
they've been laid off um but you know
that's part of what we need to do to
come together this is going to be
a challenge
that affects us in various different
ways
but we need to come together and deal
with it you know we can sit and complain
about it and we can say oh i don't get
oh i don't get to go to the ncaa
tournament game well too bad there'll be
another one next year deal with your
situation now and let's solve our
problems now and let's come together now
as a people and chris i'm i'm hopeful
that we will but man if we don't now if
this can't bring us together
nothing will i i agree this this should
be something that you know
political differences whatever it may be
uh they got to be you know
swiped out the door here right now this
is it's bigger than that and uh i'm like
i said earlier i'm just glad to see
everybody kind of making the the right
decisions here even even our own company
nbc you know i i'm proud of them they're
you know telling people hey don't come
to work you don't if you don't need to
be there for something totally drastic
or really important don't come you know
you can you can get online and do
anything you need to do you know on the
computer what do you want to say what
i'm trying
i'm i'm i want to measure my words
carefully here
because this shouldn't be political and
i don't want it to be political we need
to come together
but when i say it shouldn't be political
that also applies to our politicians and
when i hear this described as a foreign
virus yeah which we heard last night
it ain't a foreign virus we own it right
i got a foreign car
but i own it it's too late to say this
is somebody else's fault it's here it
doesn't matter how it got here it's here
looking backward or pointing fingers
elsewhere isn't going to do jack
squat right to get us out of this right
the only thing that gets us out of this
is owning it
and fixing it
and anybody who spends their time
worrying about how we got here
is wasting time that could be spent on
getting us
out of here yeah and i got no patience
for anybody on either side of the aisle
whether you're red whether you're blue
whether you're in the media whether
you're not i got no patience for anybody
that's going to take time to put blame
on others no we got to come together and
we got to fix this and we got to work
together and we got to fix this and we
got to reach across the aisle and we got
to set aside our differences and we got
to fix this
and yeah yeah no i'm with you i'm with
you well said uh i'm with you all the
way and and i think yesterday was a big
big big jump for all of us in our
country to get us going in that right
house so yeah i think so i think we're
on the right track well and here's the
thing we're going to be here until they
pull us off the air yep and uh
as long as this is a thing this is part
of who we are this is part of what we
are and this platform that we've been
fortunate enough to craft
uh i'm gonna try to use it for good here
yeah i mean i think we all have an
obligation to do that and
and we it's just i i can't overemphasize
the importance of people taking this
seriously
quit complaining quit whining process
the five stages of grief act like an
adult anger denial bargaining depression
acceptance get to acceptance that our
world has changed and it's time for us
to act accordingly and if you want to be
mad at me that i'm saying it i don't
care wake up and act like a grown up we
got to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports